Kevin Frazier was in New York for the
premiere where we got some fast facts
about the eighth installment of the
franchise first fact that rumored onset
few between Dwayne Johnson and Vin
Diesel to have fizzled you guys seem to
view inventive seemed to work out
whatever was gone
tell me about it and what is it where
does it stand now yeah well because at
the end of the day the most important
thing is making a movie right oftentimes
just like in life you have different
philosophies and people have different
philosophies different fundamental
philosophies on how you do things and
again the most important thing is just a
movie so I'm happy that we're here in
New York City I'm happy that the fans
love it I'm happy that in the movie I'm
what's that thing Oh amazing we still
love each other
that's my boy when I was making that
difficult decision should there be a
tape or not I called him he said brother
I will be there shoulder-to-shoulder
with you to make sure it's the best
movie in history fast fact number two
it's the first film in the franchise
shot since the death of actor Paul
Walker Scott Eastwood joins the team not
that you replace Paul but in a sense
coming in and joining this team after
Paul what was that like and did--no
replacing Paul ever ever ever ever Paul
was a good friend to all of us this is
his family and you know what better way
to continue his legacy did you get hazed
a little bit by these guys always first
thought they called me little nobody I
don't even know if that was in the
script uh-huh they came up with that and
it snuck in the movie fast fact number
three Tyrese told me how he pulled off
that secret Valentine's Day wedding to
his girlfriend Samantha Lee he told
friends no phones no tweets no
instagrams she happened to have and I
have an absent people in my life that
was able to respect the request that's
all it took it was the first red carpet
ever for tyreese's new wife fast fact
number four details on those dreadlocks
Charlize told me that was a heavy wig
there were such craftsmanship behind it
that I just had such appreciation for it
but at the end of the day when we took
it off it felt like 20 pounds have been
removed off my head
[Music]